Good evening.
I trust you've had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, though I hope it has been a happy day.
Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa Namo Tassa Bhagavato Arahato Sambha Sambhudassa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato samma sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one.
So just as a reminder, if the broadcasting stops, if the YouTube stops, just give me a few minutes and I should be able to get it back up again.
So we are going through the story of Upali.
So we had this Nigantha, a Jain monk, approach the Buddha and ask him what was more important, the mind, actions by the mind, or actions by speech or the body?
And according to the Jain understanding, the body is the worst thing and the mind is the least.
But according to the Buddha, the mind is the forerunner.
So I'd just like to quote the first chapter, the first verse of the Dhammapada, which I think most of you know is a collection of sayings.
The mind is the forerunner of all mental phenomena.
Mind is the chief.
They are all mind made.
And then, of course, he says, if you act with an impure mind,
Or one speaks or acts with an impure mind and pain follows or suffering follows as even as the wheel, the hoof of the ox.
And of course, there's the opposite of that if you have good thoughts, but everything begins in the mind.
That's the Buddha's point.
So he goes back, he talks to the Ngantha, Nataputra talks to the leader of the Jains.
I'll call him Mahavira from now on, because that's what they call him, Mahavira, the great man.
And he tells him what transpired.
And there's a layman there, Upali, who thinks that he will now go and convert the Buddha to this.
And so he says, of course, things like he's really showing off.
He says, I shall drag the recluse to and fro, drag him fro, drag him around and roundabout.
And then he will shake him up and thump him about.
So he's in for a big debate.
So he goes to see the Buddha.
But before he goes, Tapasi, who was the Jain monk who'd seen the Buddha previously,
says, Venerable Sir, so he's talking to Mahavira, I do not think the householder Upali should try to refute the recluse Gautama's doctrine, for the recluse Gautama is a magician and knows a converting magic by which he converts disciples of other sectarians.
Now, the Mahavira won't take that.
He says, no, no way, you'll never convert Upali.
Upali is a big, a devoted disciple of mine.
in so many words.
And of course, the usual thing, you ask him three times, three times, the Mahavira says to Upali, no, you know, go and try and convert this, the Buddha, you see.
So off he goes and he meets the Buddha at Pavarika's mango grove.
This is up near Nalanda, remember, which became a huge university.
And the Buddha, he asked the Buddha had he met Tapasi and the Buddha then tells him what conversation they had.
And so now we go back to this original statement.
What does the trivial mental rod count for the comparison with the gross bodily rod?
So this was the stick that you beat yourself with when you do something harmful.
On the contrary, he says the bodily body is the most reprehensible for the performance of evil action.
So the Buddha wouldn't deny that physical actions are probably worse.
Well, I think he would say they're worse in that effect.
But it all starts with the mind, remember.
So now the Buddha says, well, let's debate this, you know, on the basis of truth.
So he says here, Samnigamtha, so one of your
people might be afflicted, suffering and gravely ill with an illness, needing treatment by cold water, by which his vows prohibit, because cold water could have living beings in it.
Remember the James are probably the greatest example of no harm.
And they might refuse cold water, though mentally longing for it, and use only permissible hot water, thus keeping his vows bodily and verbally.
So the vow bearer is
physical and verbal.
But because he does not get cold water, he might die.
Now, House Oda, where would the Nigantha Nataputta describe his rebirth?
Oh, and Upali says, well, he will be born among the gods called the mind-bound gods.
Now, why is that?
Because he died, he was still bound by the mind.
Okay, so in other words, it was his mental acts that drove him to this particular rebirth.
So the Buddha says, oh, pay attention how you reply.
What you said before does not agree with what you said afterwards, nor does what you said afterwards agree with what you said before.
That's the first example.
So in the next one, he says, the Indiganta has
four checks uh four checks four curves clamped by four curves so these are uh two eight five here we go so these are uh the nigantra is restrained with regard to all water he's endowed with the avoidance of all evil he is cleansed by the avoidance of all evil and he is suffused with the avoidance of all evil so that is the leader the guru you see so um
And yet, when going forward and returning about the destruction of many living beings, what result does the Neganthaliputa describe?
Well, he says, well, the Mahavira does not describe what is not as greatly reprehensible.
So that's interesting.
Uh, the Buddha says anything that is not willed, in other words, that's by accident or, uh, by ignorance, not knowing, uh, for instance, I got a house once I was walking in the dark outside and there was this awful crunch under my foot as this poor snail succumbed my weight and got squashed.
And I didn't feel very well about it, but, uh, according to the Buddha, I'm not guilty of doing harm as such because there was no intention.
But in the Jain, even when you don't have intention, you're still done harm.
So therefore there's consequences.
But he says that it's not greatly reprehensible.
But if one wills it, that is greatly reprehensible, says the Venerable, said his reply.
But under which of the three rods does the Mahavira...
Describe willing under the mental rod, venerable sir.
So what he said is that the actions that you do are first of all willed, okay?
And so now he says, well, even though the action might be terrible, it all began with the will.
So now Buddha says, pay attention how you reply.
What you said before does not agree with what you said afterwards.
Have your second one.
Now, the third one is a bit of magic.
Suppose a man came brandishing a sword and said, in one moment, I will make all the living beings in this town of Nalanda one mass of flesh, one heap of flesh.
Would this be possible?
So what do you think, householder?
Would he be able to do it?
So he says, no, the householder Upali says, even if a hundred, even if a thousand of these people with a sword, they wouldn't be able to kill everybody in that town.
Now, the Buddha says, supposing a Brahmin or a recluse possessed supernormal power and attained a mastery of mind, would be able to reduce 10, 20, 30, 40, even 50 Nalanda's to ashes with one mental act of hate.
So what does a trivial act, a trivial Nalanda count for?
So in other words, the Buddha says, supposing somebody came with that sort of supernatural power,
would he be able to do it?
So Upali's just agreed, you see.
So again, the Buddha says, now pay attention.
What you said before, that mental acts weren't important, does not agree with what you've just said.
Okay, so he's got three of those now.
And then there's something which is from the Jataka tales.
Now the Jataka tales were a collection of stories about the Buddha's previous births.
And a lot of them
Some of them are actually taken from Aesop's fables, you know, the Greek author.
And they're all made up between round about 300 BC, they think, to 400 AD or Common Era, CE, if you prefer.
So there was a whole stretch of time when stories about, supposedly, supposed stories about the Buddha in his past life,
uh were concocted were well were made up so now he says in those stories the dadanka kalinga major and matanga forests became forests how did they do that how did they become forest so um replies i heard that they become forest by means of an a mental act of hatred on the part of the rishis the seals the holy men
Oh, pay attention Upali.
What you said before does not agree with what you said.
What you say now does not agree with what you said before.
So again, the Buddha is proving to Upali that the mind is first.
Now, Vrindabopali seems to have been converted by the very first example.
And he immediately says that I go to the Buddha for refuge.
I go to the Blessed One for refuge, to the Dharma, the Sangha of Bhikkhu.
So he's been converted, you see.
And the Buddha replies, investigate thoroughly, householder.
It is good for such well-known people like you to investigate thoroughly.
Now, this really pleases Upali.
He's quite taken by it because he says, you know, if I had been converted to another sect, you know, they would have carried me around.
They would have carried a banner all over Nalanda.
know telling people that upali had been converted but on the contrary the blessed one says you know be sure of uh of what you're taking on here investigate properly and then the buddha says to him your family has long supported the uh nigantas you should consider that arm should be given to them when they come so this of course is quite astonishing because uh lay people only give to those gurus whom they are disciples of now there was an occasion
when there was lots of food left over from Adana, from a meal that the Buddha and his disciples had in one of these big parks, one of these big shrines.
They were shrines mainly.
And Ananda goes to the Buddha and says, we've got all this food left over.
And the Buddha said, oh, we'll give it to these other members of these other sects, you see.
And so they did.
And then the...
The stories came back through Ananda to the Buddha who said the lay people were very upset.
They want to give food to you.
They don't want to give any food to these other rascals.
And so the Buddha established a rule.
Whatever food I receive as a dana, I can't give to members of other sects.
Not even a biscuit.
So now Upali is very pleased with that.
And then the Buddha gives him a teaching.
And right there, when he knew that the householder Upali's mind was ready, receptive, free from hindrances, elated and confident, he expounded to him the teaching special to the Buddhas,
Suffering, the origin of suffering, the cessation of suffering and the path, the Four Noble Truths.
And just as a clean cloth with all marks removed would take dye evenly, so too, while the householder Upali sat there, the spotless, immaculate vision of the Dharma arose in him.
All that is subject to arising is subject to cessation.
And so he became a Sotapanna, a stream entrant right there.
So then he left.
He's got things to do.
Now is the time, householder, to do what you think fits.
So off he goes, goes back home.
And when he goes back home, the word gets out that he has, in fact, been converted.
So when Tipasi, that's the original Jain monk, tells the Mahavira, of course, he can't believe it.
So he goes to find out.
And then when he finds out, he comes back and he tells the Mahavira, Venerable Sir, it is only too true that the householder Upali has gone over to the discipleship of the recluse Gautama.
Venerable Sir, I did not get your consent when I told you.
Venerable Sir, I do not think the householder Upali should try to refute the recluse Gautama's doctrine, for the recluse Gautama is a magician.
and know the converting magic by which he converts disciples of other sectarians so as it happens um uh the nigantha now the mahavira now goes to visit upali and he goes with a large retinue a large number of his followers and um
Upali has told the doorman that if anybody comes who is not a disciple of the Buddha, that they should wait until he comes out and greets them, you see.
So there were these, so his guru, his former guru, the Jain leader, has been asked to wait
And when Upali hears he's there, he says, go and make the seats ready in the hall of the central door.
Now, when Upali comes in, he sat down on the highest, the best, the chief and most excellent seat there.
And then he told the good doorkeeper, go to the Mahavira and tell him, please enter.
And when he enters, of course, previously, this big high seat would have been given to the Mahavira.
But it's not.
And he said, householder, the Mahavira says, householder, are you mad?
Are you an imbecile?
You went saying, venerable sir, I shall refute the recluse Gautama's doctrine.
And you've come back all caught up in his vast net.
Just as a man who went to castrate someone and came back castrated on both sides.
Just as a man went to put out somebody's eyes and came back with both his old eyes pulled out.
So you too, householder, I shall refute the Gothamer's doctrine.
You've come back all caught up in a vast net of doctrine.
Auspicious is that converting magic, venerable sir.
Good is that converting magic.
And then Upali says, I wish all my people were converted.
So then he, there's a lot of stuff here which we can miss out, the usual stuff about that.
But then towards the end of this rather long conversation with the Mahavira, Upali suddenly comes out with 10 verses, each one of which ends with,
The blessed one is he and I am his disciple.
So the last one of these ten is he has severed craving, this is the Buddha, and become the enlightened one, cleared of all clouds and completely untainted, most worthy of gifts, most mighty of spirits, most perfect of persons beyond estimation.
the greatest in grandeur attained the peak of glory.
The blessed one is he, and I am his disciple."
So the Jain leader Mahavir says, when did you concoct this hymn of praise to the recluse Gautama householder?
Venerable sir, suppose there were a heap of many kinds of flowers
and then a clever garland maker and garland maker's apprentice were to knock them up into a multicolored garland.
So too, Venerable Sir, the Blessed One has many praiseworthy qualities, many hundred praiseworthy qualities.
Who, Venerable Sir, would not praise a praiseworthy?
Then the Nigantanathaputta, the Mahavira, was so unable to bear this honor done to the Blessed One, hot blood then and there gushed from his mouth.
now the commentaries go on to say a heavy sorrow arose in him because of the loss of his lay supporter and this produced a bodily disorder that resulted in his vomiting hot blood after vomiting hot blood few beings can continue to live thus they brought him to parva on a litter and shortly thereafter he passed away now that is
two thousand over two thousand year old news yes right there in the buddhist scriptures fake news or if you wish alternative facts the uh niganta uh in the cantonate of the mahavira as he is known uh died of starvation which is uh the the way that
James would prefer to die I stand to be corrected but as I understand it so it's the body is a manifestation of your of your bad karma and the more you can leave the body the more the soul will rise up into heaven and therefore just letting go of the body just allowing it to die and stop eating
And elderly people will do that and they will see it as a way to liberation.
And when I looked up starvation, of course, virtually all the animal kingdom,
stop, you know, die when they can no longer feed themselves.
So it's the natural way.
And it would seem it's not all that, there's not much pain to it.
The body simply draws itself down and then stops.
So I can only hope that this wonderful story of Upali
has been entertaining, but also has been some teaching there about the Buddha's insistence that the mind comes first.
Everything starts with the mind.
And when you will something, it will manifest.
Either there's a train of thoughts, some fantasy or whatever, or through our speech or through our bodies.
And therefore we have to be very careful what comes up in the mind.
I can only hope that by your diligence in observing the mind,
And your practice will lead you to full liberation sooner rather than later.
So we can continue with our practice.